the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi today we finish up the last of the
basic vector operations today what we're
going to discuss is something called the
vector product or the cross product and
it's a new type of multiplication
whereby we now multiply two vectors to
obtain a vector you see the dot product
multiply two vectors but it gave a
scalar this is why the dot product was
called the scalar product now the idea
is again
we can go to the physical world to seek
motivation and my only problem with that
is that some of the examples that
motivated this are not quite as
elementary as the work equals Force
Times distance formula of last time the
cross product does come up in sort of
trivial applications in terms of moments
the angular momentum in terms of
mechanics and in more advanced
situations in terms of the Maxwell
equations where you may remember in
physics courses going through this
routine of the force and the flux and
the intensity and what have you and at
any rate rather than waste time and I
mean I use the word waste here
judiciously because for the purpose of
our course it is not nearly as crucial
to motivate why we invented the cross
product physically as it is to define it
mathematically and to use it
structurally you see what I want to do
is simply get to the crux of the
situation discuss the concept of a cross
product and simply point out that if a
and B are vectors by a cross B written
this way a cross B we mean a vector now
his the kicker again as soon as I say
vector that means to define it I have to
tell you three ingredients namely
magnitude direction and sense right now
for the magnitude of a cross B it's
simply the magnitude of a time's the
magnitude of B times the magnitude of
the sine of the angle
between a and B and I'm going to come
back and comment on that in a few
moments about the difference between the
sign here versus the cosign of the
previous lecture again physically
there's a motivation for this as far as
we're concerned all we have to do is say
this is what the magnitude is defined to
be this is the game we define it this
way next thing I have to do is tell you
its direction and the direction of a
plus B is by definition perpendicular to
both a and B right another way of saying
that is in the event that a and B are
not parallel then the vectors a and B
determine a plane and what we're saying
is that a cross B is then a vector
perpendicular to the plane determined by
a and B all right by the way if a and B
are parallel they don't determine a
plane right because they coincide they
have only one direction but if a and B
are parallel the angle between them is 0
or 180 depending on whether their sense
is the same or not once the angle is
either 0 or 180 the sine of that angle
is 0 once one of the factors here is 0
the whole product is 0 so in the event
that a and B do not determine the plane
the magnitude of a cross B is 0 which
means that a plus B is the zero vector
and that's a pretty trivial situation so
we just won't even worry about that
and thirdly I must now give you the
sense of a plus B and the sense is the
usual right hand rule in other words the
direction in which a right-handed thread
screw would turn as a is rotated into B
and now I have to be careful because of
this sine situation through the smaller
angle you see look at notice that this
sense is going to depend on what if you
rotate a into B you get the opposite
sense than if you rotated B into a and
not only that but if you rotate a into B
through the larger of the two angles
notice that rotating a into B through
one angle say the smaller one
it gives you a different sense than
rotating a and to be through the larger
the two angles there's a certain
ambiguity that comes up here and the
ambiguity occurs because of the fact
that we're using the sine rather than
the cosine in other words if you reverse
the sense of an angle if you change its
sign the algebraic sign the
trigonometric sine si n changes okay and
similarly the sine of an angle is the
negative of the sine of 360 degrees
minus that angle okay but that at any
rate is the definition of the cross
product given two vectors their cross
product is what a vector whose magnitude
is the product of the two magnitudes
times the magnitude of the sine of the
angle between the two vectors the cross
product is perpendicular to each of the
two vectors and it's senses the
right-hand rule as the first is rotated
into the second through the smaller of
the two angles okay this is important
because you see what happens is that as
important as the cross product is from a
physical point of view arithmetic aliy
it's a nuisance we can take very few
liberties with the cross product it
turns out that almost every rule that we
would like to be true about numerical
multiplication is false for vector cross
products for example among other things
a cross B is not equal to B cross a in
fact a cross B is the negative of B
cross a and the reason for this is
simply as you check this thing through a
cross B and B cross a certainly have the
same magnitude they have the same
direction because each is perpendicular
to both a and B but notice that the
sense is different namely a cross B
tells us to rotate a into B through the
smaller of the two angles and in our
particular diagram that is what the
counterclockwise direction on the other
hand B cross a says rotate B into a
through the
smaller of the two angles and if we do
that notice that we get the clockwise
direction so that B cross a and a cross
B have the same magnitude they have the
same direction but they have the
opposite sense that is a plus B is the
negative of B cross a and what that
means you see in computations is that
every time you change the order of a and
B in a cross product you must remember
to change the sign in fact what's
particularly embarrassing is if you
forget to do this if this particular
term is going to be added on to
something and you forget to change its
sign you're going to be off by more than
just the error of a sign in other words
if something was supposed to be plus
four and you have it as minus four a
vice-versa the error is going to be
eight if you add it rather than subtract
it you see so the error gets hidden in
other computations but you in other
words you can change the order of the
factors but you must remember to change
the sign another interesting thing is
that unlike in the dot product where a
dot b dot c didn't even make sense
it is true that a cross B cross C and a
cross B cross C do make sense and by the
way what are these things
they're vectors B cross C is a vector
which is perpendicular to both B and C I
mean it's purple you see and a is a
vector and the cross product of two
vectors is again a vector etc these are
two vectors but in general these two
vectors do not have to be equal in fact
as I shall show you in a moment these
two vectors don't even have to be in the
same plane let alone being equal they
don't even have to be in parallel planes
and again without making too much of a
fuss over this let's take a look and see
if we can see why let's look at a cross
B cross C by definition let's just even
look at direction let's not even worry
about magnitudes what is the direction
of a cross B cross C it must be what it
must be on the one hand perpendicular to
a and on the other hand perpendicular to
B cross C okay that's the definition of
being a cross product on the other hand
about B cross C as a vector itself B
cross C is perpendicular to both B and C
so what do you have here you have that
whatever a cross B cross C is it's
perpendicular to B cross C which in turn
is perpendicular to both B and C that
sounds like a tongue twister but if you
decipher it all it says is that a cross
B cross C is perpendicular to the
perpendicular to B and C and I call that
deciphering it
what is the perpendicular to the
perpendicular you see let's just look at
it this way
here are two vectors in the plane here's
a perpendicular I now take a
perpendicular to that and that's going
to be parallel to the original plane
this is written up in the text it's
written up as one of our learning
exercises but just for a quick
run-through now all I want you to see is
that a cross B cross C is parallel to
the plane determined by B and C in fact
the easy way to memorize this is look at
the vector that's in parenthesis and the
cross product is what it's parallel to
the plane determined by the two vectors
in parenthesis the only time these two
vectors by the way won't determine a
plane is if they're parallel but in that
case the cross product would have been 0
anyway in other words to summarize what
I've written on the blackboards here a
cross B cross C is a vector which lies
in the plane determined by B and C after
all the vector is parallel to the plane
you can assume it lies in the plane
because you can shift it parallel to
itself and correspondingly a cross B
cross C is a vector in the plane
determined by a and B in particular
there's no reason why the a B plane and
the BC plane have to be the same plane
no law says that our three vectors a B
and C all lie on the same plane so in
particular this is why the associative
property doesn't hold through a cross
product that as soon as you shift the
parenthesis you actually shift the plane
in which the vector
exists okay but again I just want to go
through these highlights to make sure
you don't miss them but these are done
in more detail in the notes before I
start blasting the cross product too
much let me point out that certain
properties that we like a numerical
arithmetic are present in the cross
product for example there is a I say
this there's a little structure the
associate the distributive property
holds for the cross product in other
words if the vector a is crossed with
the sum of the two vectors B and C and
by the way again notice if B and C of
vectors B plus C is a vector I'll put a
video to indicate vector a is a vector
and the cross product of two vectors is
a vector notice that again with the
cross product all of the things that
you're working with happen to be vectors
but my claim is that a crossed with B
plus C is equal to a cross with B plus
the product of a trust with C all right
that's a very nice structural property
again as usual Cartesian coordinates
have a lot to offer us if we switch to
Cartesian coordinates again as usual
writing a is a 1 I plus a 2 J plus a 3 K
and B is B 1 I plus B 2 J plus B 3 K and
multiplying term by term we observe a
rather interesting situation you see
notice things like this when you cross I
with I J with J and K with K you're
always going to get the 0 vector and the
reason for that is we already saw that
since the sine of the angle between two
parallel vectors is 0 the magnitude of
the cross product is 0 that means that
the cross product is the zero vector the
question comes up what happens when you
cross I with J or J with I I with k k
with J etc I think it's easy to see that
when you cross I and J and J and I
you're going to get either K on minus K
the right handed rule is set up very
very conveniently
again to help us with a memory device
the easiest way to remember how these
things go is I J and K was up to form a
right-handed rule a right-handed system
right I J and K sequentially CIJ K IJ K
etc call the normal order the positive
direction and the opposite order the
negative direction for example when you
want I cross J just read this list as
you go along
I followed by Jay gives K which is in
the right order CIJ K so I cross J is K
on the other hand J cross I means what J
followed by I J followed by I is this
way that also yields K but you're now
going in the negative direction to
summarize these results I cross J is the
same as minus J cross I which is K K
cross I is the negative of I cross K
which is J I cross I J cross J and K
cross K are all 0 and knows the youthere
of zero vector because we're dealing
with vectors and again leaving the
details to you they're very simple to
come up with just carry out the
multiplication and what you find is that
a plus B is given by the following the I
component of the vector is a2 b3 minus
a3 b2 the J component is a3 b1 minus a1
b3 and the K component is a1 b2 minus a2
b1 and if you want a convenient way of
memorizing this again right 1 2 3 in
their correct sequential order and what
you're saying is each term in a cross B
involves what an a factor followed by a
B factor the subscripts involve the
component which isn't presidency for the
first component I the subscripts are 2 &
3 for the second component J the second
component the subscripts are 3 & 1 and
for the third component K the subscripts
are 1 & 2
and notice that the way the signs are
determined is that if the subscripts
occur in the correct sequential order
it's positive otherwise negative for
example 2 followed by 3 is the correct
order but 3 followed by 2 is the
negative order notice in this sequence 1
follows 3 whereas 1 2 3 is in the
negative order see just the same this
works out very very nicely and the
reason I went through this it may seem
like an awful lot of work to go through
that to show you how logical this thing
is is that something comes up in the
textbook which is not bad but which I
find is frightening if you have not had
experience with something called
determinants you see the author
professor Thomas elects to introduce a
convenient device for memorizing this
result and he writes it as a 3 by 3
determinant and let me just write down
the 3 by 3 determinant and then we'll
talk about it later
I put convenient in quotation marks to
emphasize to you that this is convenient
only if you already know determinants if
we don't know determinants this is not
only not convenient but it's frightening
we're always frightened of things that
we don't understand too well and I call
it a memory device because you do not
have to have determinants to remember
this particular result in fact if one
we're going to list in order the reasons
for inventing determinants and the man
was reading off a very very long list
and you were getting bored as soon as he
came to the reason that it was
convenient to list the cross product you
could heave a sigh of relief because you
would know that he's near the end of the
list in other words to make a long story
short of all the reasons for inventing
determinants using them for a
cross-product representation is perhaps
the least significant but you see in
professor Thomas's approach determinants
are assumed to be known and if you do
know them it's a good it's a good
notation if you don't forget it the
trouble is I tell you to forget it and
you won't forget it it always works that
when you tell the student not to forget
something he forgets when you say please
ignore it and forget it he doesn't
forget so since you you may be a little
bit rusty on determinants let me give
you a very very brief review of
determinants in fact it's not only very
brief
it's a pseudo review because I will give
you no logic behind this at all I'm just
going to tell you the recipe first of
all by a 2 by 2 determinant you mean a
square array of numbers consisting of 2
rows and 2 columns you use absolute
value signs to indicate the determinant
and by definition the 2 by 2 determinant
a b c d is the product of the two terms
a and d minus the product of the two
terms B and C in other words if you
multiply the upper left by the lower
right and subtract from that the upper
right times the lower left that is by
definition the value of the 2 by 2
determinant okay
just by definition oh by the way in
block 7 of our course we're going to do
this in much more detail for now I just
want to give you enough of a hint so if
you are frightened by determinants you
can see what Professor Thomas is talking
about in the text here now to expand a 3
by 3 determinant one uses a little sign
code starting at the upper left-hand
corner you put a little plus sign then
you out make plus minus plus etc the
plus simply is a code to tell you leave
the sign of the term alone and the minus
tells you change the sign of the term
what that means is this by definition
this 3 by 3 determinant is obtained as
follows take X 1 as it appears and
strike out the row and column in which X
1 appears and multiply X 1 by the
remaining 2x2 determinant then what you
do is you factor out X 2 with a minus
sign strike out the row and column in
which X 2 appears and multiply X 2 by
the remaining 2 by 2 determinant that's
left similarly take our X 3 with the
sign that appears with
strike out the row and column in which
it appears and multiply by the remaining
2 by 2 determinant summarised to expand
this 3 by 3 determinant it's X 1 times
the determinant y 2 y 3 Z 2 Z 3 minus X
2 times the determinant y 1 y 3 Z one Z
3 plus X 3 times the determinant y 1 y 2
Z 1 Z 2 now that happens to have very
practical application as I say for this
particular situation I just want to do
it with you to have you see how it works
let me come back to what we were doing
before and show you how if we use this
definition we can mechanically write
down a cross V in a hurry what did the
rules say it says to expand the 3 by 3
determinant take out I as it appears and
multiply by the 2 by 2 determinant
that's left when you strike out the row
and column that I appears in okay then
it says what take out J with a minus
sign strike out the row and column
multiplied by the remaining 2 by 2
determinant then it says factor out K
and Mike out the row and column the K
appears in multiplied by the remaining 2
by 2 determinant well look it by a rule
of multiplying a 2 by 2 determinant what
is this thing here this is nothing more
than a 2 B 3 minus a 3 B 2
I'm not going to go through this because
time is short and you can carry this
operation out by yourself what I would
like you to see however is that this
term here is precisely the same as the
term we had here in other words if I
carry out this mechanical recipe I am
going to be able to get the same answer
that I get logically only without having
to worry about keeping track of things
in my head in other words if I do no
determinants it is very convenient to
write down the cut the cross product
two vectors using Cartesian coordinates
and just to illustrate that let me give
you a few examples I call this example
one find the vector perpendicular to the
plane determined by the three points one
two three five nine four and seven six
eight now you know try to visualize this
problem if you didn't know vectors try
to visualize drawing this thing to scale
trying to imagine what slope the plane
has and how you find the vector or a
line perpendicular to the plane and by
the way I don't even need the word
vector in here later I could say find a
direction but we'll worry about that
more next time the thing that I want to
emphasize here is I just very quickly
draw myself a little convenient device I
don't draw it to scale
I assume that the points a B and C are
not in the same straight line and if
they are it will become very interesting
that I simply won't get I get 0 for a
cross product to tell me that they don't
form two non parallel vectors black mark
off a B and C and the first thing I do
as always is I vector eyes I draw the
lines a B and a C and I vectorize them
that forms for me as usual the vector a
B and the vector AC remembering how I
form a vector from two points in
Cartesian coordinates again subtracting
the coordinates of the point that I'm
going from the point that I'm going to I
subtract away the coordinates of the
point that I'm leaving in other words 5
minus 1 9 minus 2 4 minus 3 the vector a
B very simply is 4 I plus 7 J plus K and
similarly the vector AC very
conveniently is 6 I plus 4 J plus 5 K
you see 7 minus 1 6 minus 2 8 minus 3 I
better stop checking these things
because what my luck I've probably
subtracted wrong and you might not
notice it if we just go through it
rapidly but look at how quickly I've got
a B and a C now now here's the beauty
what do I want
I want a vector perpendicular to the
plane determined by a B and C input
if I can find a vector perpendicular to
both a B and a C namely if a vector is
perpendicular the two lines in a plane
it's perpendicular to the plane itself
if I can find the vector perpendicular
to both a B and a C I'm home free that's
the vector I'm looking for or at least a
vector that I'm looking for do I know
conveniently a vector perpendicular to
two given vectors and the answer had
done well better hinge somehow on the
title of today's lecture being the
cross-product yes by definition if I
cross a B and a C whatever vector I get
is going to be perpendicular to the
plane determined by a B and C and now
what I'm saying is that the beauty of
Cartesian coordinates is like a now very
quickly write down what a B cross AC is
as a determinant namely i write down i
JK then I write down the components of a
B then I write down the components of AC
C four seven one six four five and now I
do what I strike out the row and column
in which I appears and the remaining 2
by 2 determinant is what 7 times 5 minus
1 times 4 in other words 35 minus 4 I
take out minus J strike out the row and
column in which J appears the remaining
2 by 2 determinant is 4 times 5 minus 1
times 6
in other words 20 minus 6 I strike out
the row and column in which K appears
the remaining 2 by 2 determinant is 4
times 4 minus 7 times 6 that's 16 minus
42 and now simplifying what do I have I
have 31 I minus 14 J minus 26 K in other
words the vector 31 I minus 14 J minus
26 K is the vector that I'm looking for
it's a vector perpendicular to the plane
and what I would like you to see is how
convenient this vector arithmetic is to
studying space geometry and in the next
lesson you know I'm going to say some
more about space geometry
but for now I thought maybe another nice
example before we finish up and let it
go at that let me just do one more
example for you and to simplify the
computation I might as well use the
vectors I've already used let's take the
same three points we had before one two
three five nine four seven six eight and
we're going to ask what is the area of
the triangle determined by these three
points and the subtlety that I wanted to
bring out here was an excuse to show you
how the magnitude of the cross product
of two vectors can be interpreted namely
look at two vectors alright call them x
and y draw them into scale from a common
point and let theta be the angle formed
between these two vectors all right
consider the parallelogram formed by
these two vectors the area of a
parallelogram is what it's the base
times the height now look at the base of
this parallelogram is the magnitude of Y
and the height of this parallelogram
member this magnitude is X so this
height is X sine theta
this is the area of the parallelogram
but notice that this is also by
definition the magnitude of X cross Y in
other words notice that this is by
definition the magnitude of X cross Y X
cross Y is a vector whose magnitude is
this in other words the magnitude of X
cross Y is the area of the parallelogram
determined by x and y which gives you a
rather nice interesting interpretation
imagine for example that x and y don't
change in length is it clear to you that
as I change the angle between x and y
the area of the parallelogram formed by
x and y changes in other words one
extreme case is when the angle between x
and y is 0 in which case the
parallelogram has no area another
extreme case is when the angle between x
and y is 90 degrees in other words x and
y are perpendicular to each other but if
the lengths of x and y remain fixed as i
alter the angle between them I alter the
area of the parallelogram determined by
them alright I just thought that's a
cute little device whereby you can
visualize how the magnitude of the cross
product of two vectors varies think of
the two vectors as at a common origin
and the magnitude is affected by the
area of that parallelogram as the angle
changes okay in order to change the
angle the area of the parallelogram
changes but at any rate getting back to
our original problem the corollary to
that is the following we already know
what the magnitude of a B cross AC is
from example 1 but what does that mean
now geometrically from what we've just
seen the magnitude of a B cross AC is
the area of the parallelogram which has
a B and a C as edges notice that that
parallelogram is precisely one half I
should say that as in say that the
triangle that we're looking for is
precisely one half the parallelogram in
other words notice that the area of the
triangle is
we won half the magnitude of a be cross
AC how do we find the magnitude of a B
cross C we square each of its components
add them and extract the positive square
root as usual without going through the
details it's simply going to be what
this particular amount and the rest is
arithmetics baby so to speak all right
now what I'm hoping is is that by this
stage of the game you now have a better
feeling as to what the cross product
means going back to the beginning of my
lecture notice that I played down the
physical applications because one of the
things that I want you to see is that
the cross product has tremendous
application just to space geometry alone
quite apart from anything else well at
any rate what I'm going to do next time
is now that we've talked about lines and
planes and what-have-you
is to get down to the Cartesian
representation of what lines and planes
would look like they play a very vital
role in the study of functions of
several variables we'll see more about
that as the course continues to unfold
so until next time goodbye funding for
the publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and Paul
Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate